alright
[Music]
hello how are you i am at 3 gonzález with
the most outstanding headlines for
today thursday november 12 starting
today all employees of
the clark county school district must work
from home those teachers who
attended classrooms for learning
virtual now they must do it from
home this comes on the same day that there
was talk about a possible change of
students returning to classrooms
for hybrid education in a
few weeks however the southern health district continues to
monitor the current
coronavirus situation  of nevada
offers
totally free coronavirus detection tests at
cheyenne high school this site will be
available today and tomorrow from 8 in the
morning until noon or until
resources run out no appointment is needed
and they serve you on a first-come, first-served basis
a new  Employment department report
shows 700
9,000 more Americans filed for unemployment
for the first time last week this is
better than expected
meanwhile nevada 8 thousand 800
more people applied for the same benefits a
little more than the
previous week and now we move on to
the weather forecast we could
have some  drizzles in the mountains
thanks to a cloudy sky, however
clear and sunny skies are expected
for the whole afternoon and thus we will
reach 60 degrees for today
have a nice day I am andrés
gonzález and this was about the
iu news  news now in spanish
[Music]